tava no flu o que ninguém sabe o que ela
quer
são receitas ainda tomou um chá de coca
cola diz pessoal e quem fala andar que
sejam muito bem vindos
é mais um vídeo e eu gostar do jac ea
são 260 irmão pessoal os nós vamos
assistir um vídeo uma viação 260 nas
ruas vai ser algo de especial a especial
porque porque é uma coisa que eu tenho
muito medo mesmo muito mesmo que é
rituais satânicos sant''anna já é coisa
do demônio sabem vão assistir este
ritual satânico militar não explora
qualquer pessoa outros equipados bora lá
em 3 2 1 11 dólar que já nessa aqui
alguma coisa gerar a carne que é para
andar lá está sequeira ou já que o jato
em ficar imagens já não era muito pior
entre o km 13 pontos pode também atrai
tanto texto que isto perceba barrar não
colaborassem dá para encarar o pv não só
pessoal eu vim até aqui dentro de uma
foto em sala como chinês a falar coisas
do ônibus
hoje eu não sei falar mas não está
formada e dentro de um círculo de sangue
tem velhos tenham enquanto olha que eu
não sei quanto tempo é que ela tem uma
porta e tem um armário só isto sou isto
a tocar com a tua mãe eu não vi nada
pois é pessoal e sobe até aqui um
cigarro a canalha que aquilo é uma
boneca
ai vai fazer aquelas cenas de vodu o né
para com isso
a boa fé de alguns casos para amparar a
puxar um pouco a água já estava vivo o
chá das drogas pronto e agora vai para
levar ou não para o neca acabou o
[ __ ] vaga com isso porque não quero
que tudo tudo tudo maluco maluco apagou
a inspiração chinesa por seu do fumo
como assim com uma chuteira que não
estava no futebol da europa não não foi
pra fora
não não pára para dar conta daquilo a
que não joga não de tudo quer roja a
cabo num kunar uga pelo passar algo que
gera um look
pelo lens sul tratará anderson e espirro
eu não sei o que se passou aqui pessoal
registo pra [ __ ] e com pessoal virou
meio que vocês acharam sobre este vídeo
meu status tudo para caraças eu acho que
ainda por cima o mais triste mas que eu
não consegui ver meu é muito é do city
para esse problema na minha frente você
me desculpe eu acho esse número não se
brinca com essas coisas portanto é não
vamos ver até o fim da quanto como as
farc por bonito vai fazer tenham gostado
fiquem bahia até a próxima